rewind Karen Warren with full courage
the radio show we are here with mr. Bob
maas vp of pro it is at top the media
and the wonderful sherry Kammler
marketing and publicity specialists and
we had filmmaker chris jones on our show
last week and he talked about social
media possibly being the emperor's new
clothes that maybe it was really just a
waste of time for anyone trying to build
an audience curious what's your take on
that you know I'll go first most
definitely not and Christians knows that
himself because he's done nothing for
the last year or two in building an
audience for himself using blogs using
social media not using advertising you
know not using the old traditional
method so I think more his concern was
how can I take an audience of a few
thousand and turn them into four million
can you do that with social media no no
I don't think that you can but I don't
think that independent film is going to
have audiences of four million people
that's a widespread mass commodity and
that's not what independent film is so
if that's your goal to reach four
million people you need to go in the
studio system and get going on that and
they spend millions of dollars to reach
as many people and make very mass-market
films not particularly creative
sometimes creative but that's not the
goal to be creative it's to to service
the wide audience social media is used
to form relationships individually you
can't form a relationship with four
million people but you can with a few
thousand people very engaged very
evangelistic rabid fans you can't get
that from advertising one-way
communication the way you communicate
with them is through these channels
through your blog's through yours
media pages through Twitter that's how
you build a relationship and it's not
going to be robotic it's not going to be
one way that's what you use it for and
if you don't use it for that then you're
wasting that tool you're using it
improperly and you won't build an
audience by using an ads and advertising
platform well there's probably a little
bit of a there's probably a difference
in how you use the term social media to
write is a lot like a lot of people like
well do I have to tweet we're gonna have
to use Twitter do I have to have a
Facebook page and the answer is no of
course you don't right like what there's
the way to think about it is social
media is about using the web to have
people who like your content tell other
people who might like your content about
your content right it's about how does
how does your fan become marketer for
you right that's really all you have to
think about if say okay look did i do i
have tools in place where someone who
loves my artwork isn't that person is
empowered to tell as many people as
they're connected to about my work right
so of a practical example all right you
can use Facebook as a practical example
the facebook news feed is basically
everyone you are connected to
recommending things to you right so if
someone that you're friends with on
Facebook sees the film and likes it it
makes a post about it they've just told
everyone that they're connected to 5 600
some cases people hey I really enjoyed
this film that piece of marketing right
and it is marketing right that is an ad
impression right if you think about it
is way more valuable than did I see the
billboard on Ventura Boulevard as I
drove by or did I see the ad in the
airport on them you know as I was going
down the moving walkway right that
because what happened is that's a
trusted source it's somebody that you
know who you trust whose tastes you know
says to you I saw this thing it was
great right word of mouth advertising
has existed since the dawn of products
right in the cave there was the guy with
the big rock and The Little Rock and the
big rock worked better for smashing
stuff then the little rock did and so he
told everybody and showed them how much
better it worked and everybody used the
big rock right that's word of mouth
advertising so if you replace
word-of-mouth advertising with social
media in
Chris's comment I think you end up with
a very very different sort of automatic
reaction to it right no one would ever
say is word-of-mouth advertising worth
worth paying attention to or worth
investing time and effort in right word
of mouth advertising is the most
powerful you know valuable long-term
long-term kind of advertising you can
and promotion that you can get right no
there's nothing nothing more powerful
than someone telling you about your
products and that they love it so these
services Facebook Twitter you know
individual blogs myspace anything that's
anything where people connect kneeing
right what people connect with each
other online is just really efficient
word-of-mouth communication right I can
now whereas you know two years ago I
wasn't connected in my you know the girl
from the girl I dated in high school
online right now I can give her record
recommendations I have been having to
think about am I giving them to her I
can give him seven hundred people at
once and be done this out was great you
should hear it that's what the social
media services are about so if a lot of
people create a big mass on facebook and
people who are in your audience that
you're trying to reach have congregated
there you should probably be there right
and you should put your book but you
don't need to be there broadcasting your
updates what you need to be doing is
being there engaging in the conversation
and facilitating them talking to each
other about your your artwork I mean is
that right you recommend that right
that's what i recommend yeah i mean
Oh